اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اقتحم اكثر من 300
مستوطن يهودي باحات المسجد الاقصى تحت
حمايه قوات الاحتلال في حادث بات يتكرر
بوتيره متزايده وقد دعت ئات اسلاميه عده
الفلسطينيين كافه الى التوافد على الاقصى
لحمايته نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما هي اهداف اسرائيل الحقيقيه من
تكرار اعتداءاتها على المسجد
الاقصى ولماذا لا يلتفت العرب الى المخاطر
التي تحدق بمصير القدس وبقيه الاراضي
الفلسطينيه
المحتله
في غفله من العرب تسعى اسرائيل وبشكل حثيث
الى تكريس احتلالها للاراضي الفلسطينيه
وجعل تهويدها امرا
واقعا بصور عده وباجراءات متلاحقه تحاول
اسرائيل تغيير هويه القدس المحتله بصفه
خاصه فقد احاطت المدينه بالمستوطنات
وتوسعت بهدم بيوت المقدسيين وسحب هويتهم
والتضييق عليهم لدفعهم لترك المدينه
المقدسه لكن احدث اساليب الاسرائيليين
المتسارعه لفرض الامر الواقع في القدس هي
تلك الانتهاكات والاعتداءات المتكرره بحق
الاقصى في محاولات لا تتوقف لخلق واقع
جديد بشان المسجد
والمدينه نبدا النقاش بعد تقرير زياد
بركات لم تعد هاجس العرب يتذكرها بعضهم
اذا اذا اصبحت حدثا في الاخبار يحيي
المستوطنون اليهود ما يسمونها ذكرى خراب
الهيكل يقتحم العشرات منهم باحات المسجد
الاقصى ويشتبك مع الفلسطينيين فتعود القدس
الى الواجهه ولو لبعض الوقت لكن القدس
ليست الاقصى فقط انها كبرى المدن
الفلسطينيه التي احتلها الاسرائيليون عام
67 من القرن الماضي وتكتسب اهميه رمزيه
[__] ثنائيه لكونها تحتضن المسجد الاقصى
على ما يمثله من دلالات دينيه لعموم
المسلمين قامت اسرائيل بضمها عام
1980 لكن قرارها هذا لم يكتسب شرعيه من اي
نوع فقد سارعت الامم المتحده في حينه
لاعتبار القرار باطلا ومخالفا للقانون
الدولي بل وصدر قراران دوليان ضده
وباستثناء دول قليله جدا فان الغالبيه
الغالبه من دول العالم لا تعترف بقرار
اسرائيل اعتبار القدس عاصمه لها لكن ذلك
لم يمنع اسرائيل من اتخاذ اجراءات احاديه
الجانب لتغيير هويه المدينه وفرض امر واقع
على الارض فقد احيطت وسطن بالمستوطنات
وتقدر الاحصاءات عدد المستوطنين بنحو ربع
مليون كما توسعت اسرائيل في سياسه هدم
بيوت المقدسيين وسحب هوياتهم والتضييق
عليهم لدفعهم
لمغادرتها لكن رمزيه المدينه ظلت تشكل
تحديا يحول دون تنفيذ ما تخطط له اسرائيل
وظل سكانها يقاومون تهجيرهم واكثر من ذلك
كانوا يشتبكون مع الجنود الاسرائيليين
والمستوطنين كلما سعوا لمزيد من الخطوات
الاستفزازيه ويعتبر وضع المدينه بعد ملف
اللاج من اعقد الملفات على طاوله
المفاوضات الفلسطينيون يعتبرونها وفقا
لميثاق الوطني عاصمه لدولتهم
المرتجاة احد اسباب انهيار مفاوضات كام
ديفيد وطابه بين الرئيس الفلسطيني ياسر
عرفات ويهود براك ويعتقد ان مسعى اسرائيل
لفرض مزيد من الامر الواقع في القدس رد
استباقي من نتنياهو على المبادره الفرنسيه
او اي مسع جديد لتحريك عمليه السلام
المجمده ذلك في راي البعض لا يعني العرب
في شيء في قمتهم الاخيره تحدثوا كثيرا عن
القضيه الفلسطينيه في كلماتهم وذلك
بالنسبه لهم يكفي
ويزيد موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من
القدس كل من مسؤول ملف القدس في حركه فتح
حاتم عبد القادر والكاتب الصحفي والمحلل
السياسي روني شكيد ومن رام الله الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي الدكتور عبد الستار قاسم
ابدا معك سيد حاتم عبد القادر برايك ماذا
ترمي اسرائيل من وراء حمايه ودعم
المستوطنين في عمليات اقتحام الاقصى رغم
ما يثيره ذلك من توترات واحداث امنيه
ايضا يعني اولا دعني عندك وجه التحيه الى
ثله
المرابطين الذين استطاعوا رغم قله عددهم
ان يمنعوا اكثر من 600 مستوطن ومثلهم من
الشرطه الاسرائيليه من اداء صلوات
التلموديه
داخل مدينه يعني داخل مسجد الاقصى المبارك
رغم الاعتقالات
رغم يعني رغم اطلاق النار واطلاق القنابل
الغازيه عليهم الا انهم استطاعوا ان
يمنعوا هذا المخطط الاستيطاني الاجرامي
داخل مسجد الاقصى المبارك بالتاكيد
اسرائيل تحاول يعني استغلال هذه
الاقتحامات من اجل فرض امر واقع جديد داخل
مسجد الاقصى المبارك محاوله
لسلب يعني يعني يعني سحب ال نوع من لك
وصايه الاردنيه على المسجد الاقصى المبارك
مصادره صلاحيه الاوقاف الاسلاميه في مدينه
القدس الامر لم يقتصر فقط على الاقتحامات
وانما اسرائيل اصبحت تعتقل حراس المسجد
الاقصى المبارك اصبحت تعتقل المهندسين
اصبحت تمنع الاعمار اصبحت تمنع ادخال مواد
من اجل الترميم داخل مسجد الاقصى المبارك
بمعنى انها تحاول مصادره دور الاوقاف
الاسلاميه وفرض واقع جديد داخل مسجد
الاقصى المبارك وهذا بالتاكيد مرفوض
بالنسبه للفل فلسطينيين ولن نقبل به باي
شكل من الاشكال روني شكيد لماذا تسعى
اسرائيل دائما الى ابتزاز الفلسطينيين
و من خلال حمايه هؤلاء المستوطنين في
اقتحامهم للاماكن المقدسه الاسلاميه
للمسجد الاقصى
تحديدا اهلا وسهلا بكم اهلا الاخ حاتم عبد
القادر وال دكتور الكاسم لازم نفهم شيء
مهم جدا جدا وخليني افهم الناس شو شو
المشكله ه اول شيء الهيكل كان بالمحل اللي
بالحرم الشريف او بالاكسى هذا مكان مقدس
برضه لليهود اما اغلبيه الاغلبيه تبع
اليهود اللي موجودين في اسرائيل ممنوع
عليهم يدخلوا للحرم للحرم الشريف من من من
اسباب دينيه في في فرقه اللي هي مش اكثر
من 5000 واحد في كل اسرائيل وانا بقول
الشيء هذا بمسؤوليه كبيره 5000 واحد في كل
اسرائيل مش اكثر منهم هدول المستوطنين
المتطرفين اللي بدهم يدخلوا للحرم الشريف
وبدهم يغيروا الودع اللي موجود هناك
بالحرم
الشريف رس الدايه واسرائيل اسرائيل
اسرائيل ما ت ولا ولا واحد لا لا ولا واحد
اليوم بالمحل المقدس اسرائيل عم تسوي مع
كل جهودها انه تحفظ على ستاتوس كو اللي
كان هناك من سنه
1977 برضو نتنياهو نفسه هو حكى احنا ما
راح نغير الوضع بالحرم الشريف ثالثا ولازم
نفهم الشيء هذا قبل سنتين اسرائيل او
الاردن الملك عبد
الله الملك عبد الله جلاله الملك عبد الله
قال بدنا نحط كاميرات بالح الحرم الشريف
عن شان نشوف شو شو موجود هناك شو المشاكل
اسرائيل وافقت على الشيء هذا كان مشاكل لا
بد انه كان مشاكل اخيرا الفلسطينيون قالوا
ما بدنا كاميرات وفيش كاميرات اذا كانت
كاميرات
اليومم لماذا تسمح اسرائيل لماذا تسمح
اسرائيل
بعمليه الاقتحام هذه وهي تعرف مسبقا ما
يمكن ان تثيره من ازمات لماذا تسمح لهم في
مقابل انها تضييق على الفلسطينيين في حقهم
اكان في الصلاه اثناء صلاه الجمعه او حتى
في المناسبات الدينيه
الاخرى اول شيء بالمناسبات الدينيه وفي
يوم الجمعه ولا يهودي بيدخل الحرم الشريف
انا بقول شده الموريه كامله لا مش تض اوكي
ثانيا اسرائيل عم تعطي لانه ما بدها تكسر
الستاتوس كو اللي انبنى هان في 67
الي يهود كان يدخل الحرم مع كل الاسف انا
بقول بالاربع خم سنوات الاخيره في فركات
تبع المستوطنين المتطرفين اللي بدهم
يدخلوا الحرم بدون ما يفهموا الخطر
موجو ما تع انه ولا
واحد
ي عش
ناس
نعم ما رايك فيما فيما سم طبعا السيد
شكيد هو يتحدث وكان اسرائيل حمامه
سلام تحدث عن المحافظه على الوضع
القائم كيف حافظت اسرائيل على الوضع
القائم هي انتهكت كل شيء وانتهكت القوانين
الدوليه مرارا وتكرارا ولم تستمع الى
قرارات صادره عن الجمعيه العامه للامم الم
المتحده او عن مجلس الامن هي لم تحافظ على
الوضع الذي كان قائما منذ عام
1967 واكبر دليل على ذلك انا لا استطيع
ادخل القدس لاصلي فعن اي وضع قائم يتحدث
الشيء الاخر عندما هو يتحدث عن مقدسات
لليهود في القدس هذه مساله تحتاج الى
تحقيق وتحقق تاريخي هناك كلام انه كان لهم
مقدسات لكن في هناك ايضا ب بض الباحثين
سواء في الدول الغربيه او في الدول
الشرقيه يقولون ان اليهود لم يكن لهم
مقدسات هنا يعني مثلا المؤرخ الامريكي
تومسون يضح هذا الكلام تماما طيب
السامريون في نابلس يضحون هذا الكلام
تماما وعلى ذلك نقيس المساله اخي الكريم
ان القدس
الان يتم الاستفراد بها هي يتيمه وفقط من
يرعاها هم نفر قليل من المرابطين في الحرم
القدسي الشريف ما عدا ذلك لا دول عربيه
تصنع شيئا ولا سلطه فلسطينيه اقصى ما
يصنعونه هو التحدث الاعلامي بعض التصريحات
الاعلاميه خاليه المضمون والتي لا يتبعها
عمل اصلا ام وبالتالي يجب نحن ان نعيد قرا
سنناقش استراتيجيه عمل عفوا سيد عبد
الستار هذه النقطه سنناقشها في في الجزء
الثاني من حلقتنا لكن سؤالي لك هنا فيما
يتعلق وبما انك تتحدث عن الشواهد
التاريخيه وصراع ديني ما لا تعتقد بان
اسرائيل تسعى فعلا الى حصر مشكله القدس
التي هي مشكله اولا رمزيه للقضيه
الفلسطينيه ثم هي مشكله ارض فلسطينيه
محتله حصرها برمز دينيه معينه وبصرا ديني
محدد داخل المسجد
الاقصى
نعم هي اسرائيل تحاول ان تغيب كل القوانين
الدوليه وكل القرارات الدوليه هي تعمل على
تغييبها وبعدين هي تعمل على تغييب ارهاب
يعني الاحتلال بحد ذاته
ارهاب واكثر دوله محتله الان في العالم هي
اسرائيل والاحتلال ارهاب بسبب الاجراءات
القاسيه والملاحقات المستمره التي تقوم
بها ضد الشعب الفلسطيني ولهذا يجب ان يكون
هنا قرارات عربيه واسلاميه ودوليه ضد
الارهاب الصهيوني نحن ما بنعاني من ارهاب
داعش فقط فيما هو احط واقذر واسوا من
ارهاب التنظيمات المتطرفه في السح العربيه
نعم ابقى معي سيد عبد الستار فقط اريد ان
اسال سيد حاتم عبد القادر ما رايك باتيكو
الذي تحاول اسرائيل الحفاظ عليه داخل
المسجد الاقصى كما يقول روني
شكيد
يعني انا بستغرب من الصحفي روني شكيت وهو
المتابع للشان الاسرائيلي ومتابع الاحداث
في القدس المسجد الاقصى المبارك عن اي
ستيكو يتحدث المقصود بالحفاظ على
الستاتيكو هو الستاتيكو الذي وضعه بن يمين
نتنياهو للمسجد الاقصى المبارك وليس الذي
كان قائما عام
1967 اسرائيل اولا غيرت كل الوضع القائم
الان زمام الامور داخل حرم بيد الشرطه
الاسرائيليه ولا يعني هناك تقليص لدور
الاوقاف هناك سماح للمستوطنين بدخول بدون
اي احترام للمشاعر الدينيه الاسلاميه داخل
مسجد الاقصى المبارك هناك منع لاعمال
الترميم داخل مسجد الاقصى المبارك ولذلك
لم يعد هناك وضع قائم يعني كما كان سابقا
وانما الوضع القائم الذي تحاول اسرائيل
فرضه على المسجد الاقصى المبارك هذا اولا
ثانيا الامر لا لم يقتصر على متطرفين يعني
الان كل مكونات المجتمع الاسرائيلي تح
حاول دخول المسجد الاقصى المبارك زمان
كانوا يقول عنهم مجانين ومهووس ومتطرفين
اليوم في اعضاء كنيست وزراء من الليكود
يدخلون المسجد الاقصى المبارك ولذلك انا
اعتقد ان اسرائيل تحاول تسييس الوضع في
المسجد الاقصى المبارك واستغلال التطرف
الديني اليهودي لتحقيق اهداف سياسيه داخل
مسجد الاقصى المبارك ولذلك لا يوجد وضع
قائم كما كان في العام 67 وانما اسرائيل
تحاول كل يوم فرض واقع جديد على المسجد
الاقصى المبارك وايضا تريد تحويل القدس
ليس فقط الى عاصمه سياسيه لاسرائيل وانما
ايضا عاصمه دينيه للشعب اليهودي في كل
انحاء العالم من خلال شطب المسلمين
والمسيحيين من مدينه
القدس سيد حتم عبد القادر روني شكيد
والدكتور عبد الستار قاسم ابقوا معي
مشاهدينا فاصل قصير نواصل بعده هذا النقاش
ابقوا
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد في حلقتنا هذه التي
تناقش اهداف اسرائيل من وراء اقتحامات
المستوطنين والمتطرفين للمسجد الاقصى
واعود للنقاش روني شكيد من
القدس لماذا تسعى اسرائيل الى
تسييس هذا الوضع واستغلال التطرف من اجل
فرض امر واقع بعد ان غيرت كل ما كان قائما
منذ العام
67 اول شيء انا لازم اقول يا سلام عليكم
لعبد لدكتور القاسم هو بده يقول لي انه ما
كان الهيكل ما كان بالمحل بالحرم الشريف
بالمره زي ما زي ما بده يسمع كلام من
الطرف مش مسلم المس مسلم انه يقول انه
الاشياء اللي انكتبت بالقران مش مضبوطه
ومش حقيقه انا اسف الهيكل كان هناك في
اثباتات الثوه هي
الثوه موضوعنا ليس موضوع ديني موضوعنا
عفوا موضوعنا ليس موضوع ديني وليس نقاش
ديني ولا نريد ان ندخل في القضايا الدينيه
السيد عبد الستار قاسم قال الموضوع
الموضوع يحتاج الى الموضوع يحتاج الى
دراسه تاريخيه لا اكثر ولا اقل ثم نحن
نتحدث في العامل
هذا كان هذا كان نتحدث في الموضوع السياسي
سؤال
سؤال نرجع للموضوع السياسي استغلال
اسرائيلي سياسي لوضع ديني معين هذا هو
السؤال الموض الموضوع السياسي مربوط
بالموضوع الديني لازم نقول في صوت عالي
الشيء هذا برضه عن المسلمين وبرضه عن
اليهود هذا شيء مفهوم وكل واحد بيعرف
الشيء هذا الاكسى هي رمز سياسي مش بس رمز
ديني الحرم الشريف الهيكل هو الرمز رمز
قومي مش بس رمز ديني لليهود مع كل الاسف
انا زي ما انا اقول زي ما انا قلت اغلبيه
الشعب في اسرائيل انا ما بد الشيء هذا اما
مع كل الاسف في ناس اللي بدهم اللي بدهم
يخربوا الوضع وبيسوي مع كل جهودهم
والحكومه انا ب ما لازم نكر الاشي هذا في
عننا ح حكومه يمنيه في حكومه يمنيه في
اسرائيل انا بحكي على الوزير اوري اريل
انا بحكي على الوزير بنت انا بحكي على
الوزيره ميري ريجف اللي هم بيستعملوا
الوضع الديني عن شان عشان يكسبوا قوه قوه
سياسيه وانا اسف جدا انه هذا هو على حساب
المحل الديني في القدس انا بقول لازم نرجع
للاشيء الواضع الكام اللي كان يهود
بسلوا بالمكه مسلمين
بلوا بالحرم الشريف و بيقدروا المسلمين
يدخلوا لمكه عن سب تسييس هذا الوضع يعني
انت لم تجبني عن ع ما تقوم به اسرائيل على
على الصعيد السياسي خصوصا وانه الموضوع
الان كما ذكرت ليس له علاقه باساطير
تلميذيه وغير ذلك هذا موضوع اخر هذا موضوع
اخر انا نحن هنا نسال عن التغيير العام
يعني فرض امر واق في القدس وهناك ايضا
تهويد لمدينه القدس بشكل عام وهذا ايضا
امر سياسي مرتبط بكل ما يجري في المسجد
الاقصى روني شكيد اوكي اوكي التهويد
بالنسبه للقدس ولازم نفهم الشيء هذا بدا
سنه
1968 صاروا يبنوا كل المحلات بالقدس وانا
لا ولازم نقول في اليوم 250 الف يهودي
اللي
ساكنين بال بالمحل اللي كان هناك
قبل تب
1967 اما لازم نفهم شي كبير اتضحت الفكره
سيد عبد الستار النقطه النقطه الاساسيه
التي ذكرها روني شكيد هي انه لا يمكن فصل
الديني عن السياسي وما يجري في القدس هو
جزء من هذا الصراع ما
رايك هذا اخي الكريم يتعلق بالفكر اليهود
المبني على التوراه التي نرى انها كتاب
ليس حقيقيا وليس تاريخيا انما كتب في بلاد
ما بين النهرين سنه حوالي 600 قبل الميلاد
وبالتالي اصالته التاريخيه مشكوك فيها
فبالنسبه لليهود هم لا يميزون بين القوميه
والدين القوميه يهودي والدين يهودي فما
فيها التمييز ودائما فيها الخلط بالفكر
التوراتي وبالفكر التلمودي اللي نحن
المفروض نكون دارسين لمثل هذه الاشياء حتى
نستطيع ان نقف في الساحه الدوليه ونقول
علما مش فقط شعارات بدك تتحدث علم فنعم هم
هم يعتبرون ذلك لكن اخي الكريم انا دعني
اقول ان هو شاكيد ناقض نفسه في كلمته
الاولى قال ان اسرائيل تحافظ على الوضع
القائم والان قال انه بدا تهويد القدس عام
1967 نحن بدنا نعرف منه مين الصح انه في
محافظه على الوضع القائم ا ان هناك محاوله
تهويد طبعا نحن نرى التهويد والتهويد الان
يغزو الضفه الغربيه طيب انت
هنا الم انت في البدايه في البدايه قلت
بانه القدس الان متروك القضيه اساسا
كلها متروكه
ويتيمه باختصار اريد منك كيف يمكن اعاده
تبني هذه القضيه من جديد من قبل من من قبل
العالم
العربي هو بدايه قبل الوطن العربي نحن يجب
ان نتحدث عن الفلسطينيين ام ماذا يعمل
الفلسطينيون من اجل المحافظه على القدس
حتى الان لا يوجد جديه في الساحه
الفلسطينيه للمحافظه على القدس يعني مثلا
المرابطون في المدينه من الذي يرعاهم ومن
الذي يدعمهم ومن الذي يرفع معنوياتهم يعني
اين البعد رسمي في هذا الشان في المقارنه
مع الاسرائيليين كل الانتهاكات التي يقوم
بها المستوطنون لها رعايه رسميه وتشجيع
رسمي وهذه سياسه رسميه لحكومه اسرائيل طيب
الان نحن نحن بحاجه الى الى قياده للمسجد
الاقصى تنتشر في العالم الاسلامي طيب اسمح
لي انق لعمليه التوعيه والتحري اسمح لي
انقل هذه هذه الفكره الى السيد حاتم عبد
القادر اين هي الرعايه لهؤلاء المرابطين
سيد حاتم عبد القادر وان مسؤوليه السلطه
هنا و يعني الامكانات المتوفره للمواجهه
تفضل يعني اعتقد انه هؤلاء المرابطين
يدافعون على المسجد الاقصى المبارك ولا
ينتظرون شيئا ولا رعايه ولا دعما من احد
هؤلاء هم لديهم انتماء ويدافعون عن المسجد
هؤلاء مقدسيون هؤلاء اخواننا من داخل الخط
الاخضر من يستطيع الوصول الى الضفه
الغربيه يعني السؤال هو ليس ليس السؤال من
الذي يدعمهم هو السؤال انه انه انه ماذا
قدم الفلسطينيون او ماذا قدمت السلطه ماذا
قدم العرب والمسلمين لمدينه القدس هذا هو
السؤال انا اعتقد ان هناك تقصير يعني غير
مسبوق في دعم مدينه القدس بصوره عامه
الحديث لا يعني ال يعني يعني هذا القصور
لا يتعلق فقط ب المجلد الاقصى المبارك
وانما بكل مكونات الحياه داخل مدينه القدس
لانه لا معنى للمسجد الاقصى المبارك بدون
وجود قدس وبدون وجود مقدسيين انا اعتقد ان
المقدسيين يعانون اسرائيل تحاول يعني خلق
جحيم داخل مدينه القدس دون ان يكون هناك
اي رعايه اي دعم حقيقي من السلطه
الفلسطينيه قد تكون السلطه الفلسطينيه ليس
عنك لدي امكانيات ولكن ايضا هناك مسؤوليه
عربيه هناك مسؤوليه اسلاميه نحن بالاول
الاخيره مثلا لم نر منقف المري وزاره
الخارجيه الفلسطينيه تقول انها ستدعو انها
ستدعو الى اجتماع طارق للجامعه العربيه
منظمه تعاون
الاسلامي على مستوى المندوبين وتتوجه
للامم المتحده هل ما زالت يعني هذه
المنظمات قادره على ان تفرض ولو معنويا
شيئا ما ايضا
باختصار هذه منظمات انا اعتقد هذه منظمات
مشلوله لا طائل من ورائها هناك جامعه دول
العربيه لم تفعل شيئا منظمه تعاون
الاسلامي لم تفعل شيئا القمه العربيه في
موريتانيا مؤخرا لم تفعل شيئا لجنه القدس
بالمغرب لن تفعل شيئا ولذلك نحن ت سئمنا
من التغني والشعارات واصدار بيانات نحن
الان نراهن على ابناء شعبنا نراهن على
المرابطين ولذلك نحن نقول للامه العربيه
والاسلاميه انه يجب ان تتحمل مسؤوليتها
ولكن في حال عدم تحمل هذه المسؤوليه نحن
كفلسطينيين سوف نستمر بالصمود والرباط
وبالتالي نحن سوف نخوض هذه المعركه
منفردين لاننا ندافع شرا عن كرامه الامه
العربيه والاسلاميه هؤلاء الذين يدافعون
بالاقصى يدافعون عن كرامه الامه العربيه
والاسلاميه شكرا لك حاتم عبد القادر
حدثتنا من القدس مسؤول ملف القدس في حركه
فتح وشكرا لعبد الستار قاسم الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي حدثنا من رام الله
وشاركنا ايضا في هذه الحلقه روني شكيد من
القدس حلقتنا انتهت من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده
فيما وراء خبر
جديد
ا